♪ ♪
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, SO EARLIER
TODAY SLEEPY, CREEPY CRAZY UNCLE
JOE BIDEN TO HANDLE
PRESIDENT TRUMP ON THE DEBATE
STAGE.
HERE IS WHAT HE SAID.
>> HE IS MAKING FUN OF YOUR AGE,
YOUR MENTAL STATUS AND GOING
AFTER YOU IN A WAY, I MEAN.
>> JOKINGLY.
COME ON, RUN WITH ME, MAN.
>> COME ON, MAN, HOW MANY
PUSH-UPS CAN YOU DO?
YOU CAN TELL THE PRESIDENT IS
BUSY CLEANING UP THE MESS YOU
LEFT, I WILL TAKE YOU UP ON THE
CHALLENGE.
YOU NAME THE TIME IN THE PLACE
AND I'M READY.
I DON'T -- TELL ME WHERE AND
WHEN.
THAT IS ALL THE TIME WE HAVE
LEFT.
WE WILL NEVER BE THE DESTROYED
HATE MEDIUM UP, LET YOUR HEART
NOT BE TROUBLED, LAURA INGRAHAM
OR BOTH OF US.
>> Laura: NOT BAD.
PROBABLY BOTH BIDEN AND TRUMP,
NO PROBLEM WHATSOEVER.
>> Sean: WHAT YOU SAY THAT?
>> Laura: I DON'T CARE.
I CAN DO MORE PUSH-UPS THAN
EITHER BIDEN OR HIM, BUT THAT IS
NOT REALLY COME I MEAN THEY HAVE
A FEW YEARS ON ME AT LEAST, BUT
LET ME TELL YOU, HANNITY IT
ALWAYS COMES DOWN TO THAT FOR
GUYS, DOESN'T IT?
A PLAYGROUND THING, OH, COME ON,
NO.
HE WANTS TO SHOW HE STILL GOT
IT.
HE'S A STRONG INTELLECT.
>> Sean: JOE HAS NO ENERGY.
HIS OWN TEAM KNOWS IN A SECOND